so I'm just trying to figure out if this
thing is either dr. jumba's experiment
626
[Applause]
big props anyone who understood the
reference of that opening yak so Doctor
Who the Saranga conundrum episode 5 of
series 11 and there's a number of things
going on here that I think we're done
quite well I found quite interesting I'm
really continuing to really appreciate
the development of Grandma Ryan's
relationship I feel like there's a
decent amount of work being done in
developing actually both of them
individually these characters but also
their relationship with each other is
something that keeps getting touched
back on in small ways and more prominent
ways depending on the episode it's a
little more prominent here but looking
at what we've gotten so far for the
series arc I'm liking that quite a bit
Jodie Whitaker's is doing fine
like I'll say what I've continued to say
I have yet to have the moment where I
fall in love with her but I don't when I
say that I don't mean that as a
criticism it took basically almost an
entire series for me to fall in love
with Capaldi book by the time he was
done he was one of my favorite doctors
so you know I don't need to fall in love
with the doctor right off the bat um I
still have no issue with her portrayal
of the doctor one thing I didn't I
absolutely liked a lot was I really
liked her dynamic with sort of the head
medical guy on this ship because you
know they get they get into an accident
she's she's finding herself in a lot of
really dangerous situations with her
companions that she basically gets
rescued by luck by a third party it's
like the second time that that's
happened this blatantly at the start of
an episode in any case the guy used like
captaining the ship in is the main guy
there I found that dynamic between him
and the doctor to be really fascinating
because basically he pushed back against
her with the exact kind of authority and
approach that the doctor usually uses to
sort of take command of a situation it
was really
interesting to see that dynamic kind of
flipped and it could have come across
basically as the doctor taking a
subservient role and with this being the
first time the doctor has been a woman
that could have read very badly I
personally don't think he came across
that way at all I think enough was
established showed the doctor is still
kind of a little bit off her game
you know recovering from the sonic mind
that they ran into at the very start of
the episode so I was okay with it on
that basis and then in addition to that
I think it was just a well explored
dynamic so it's a real shame that that
character gets ejected and then blown up
I don't know about a third of the way
into the episode and nothing that
remains is as interesting or dynamic as
that relationship was so this episode
it feels very reminiscent of say 42
which is another Chris Chibnall written
episode you know from back in Tennant's
era and not so much in necessarily in
terms of tone and everything else but I
mean just in the general sense of
there's nothing really wrong with it
I'll have specific nitpicks but there's
nothing really that stands out about it
either I mean even the things that I
mentioned are nice but they're not
they're not strong enough to make me go
like I want to watch this episode again
for that one thing they're not that like
there are episodes that I don't think
are that good but we'll still like have
all but there's that thing I want to
watch that again I mean something like
of how these speech in the Zygon
inversion is a is a good example because
I think a lot of people really
overpraise that two-parter pretty much
on the strength of that speech whereas
the two-part or itself that speech aside
has a lot of problems but like it has
that thing that's the thing this episode
doesn't have a thing like I said the the
most interesting guest character gets
removed fairly early on and whoever's
left is pretty bog-standard I mean as
soon as there's a pregnant character I
mean pregnant guy in this case as soon
as there's a pregnant character like you
know they're going to go into labor on
it
an opportune time that's just duh it's
it's it's check-offs pregnancy is what
it is although I will say I liked the
little twist in the explanation of why a
guy is pregnant because you know I mmm
sort of extraterrestrial alien unusual
space situations a guy is pregnant it's
not exactly a new thing I mean you know
the Orval kind of had it in his first
season I mean for crying out loud
red dwarf did it decades ago so it's not
exactly new ground but I did like the
little detail that with his species men
give birth to men when we give birth to
women that's kind of cool I kind of like
that it's not just a flip of oh well you
know this is in this species the men
just have the babies like no we're gonna
do it differently than that that was
kind of a nifty idea like it didn't make
having a pregnant character who goes
into labor
during the climax of the episode anymore
original but I mean it was any little
spin on it so there's that I think if
there's a major failing of this episode
it's the design on the creature the
pitting which first of all it just
sounds like onomatopoeia oh my god I
what a weird name but it it's too cute
I'm not saying you can't have a cute
alien but generally if the if doctor
who's gonna do a cute alien it's usually
not something that is gonna be this
directly threatening so like the adipose
are cute but the adipose themselves
aren't really an active threat so like
this this thing brought to mind the
Slovene in that it's supposed to be
threatening but it's this chubby cheeked
cute kind of thing and that takes a lot
of the impact out of it especially when
paired with the music now I want to be
clear the music is not bad
but there was a massive disconnect when
I'm hearing the music basic the music is
telling me this is super dangerous and I
look down and
Oh like its stitches chubby cousin you
know it's the visual hole of what this
creature looked like and what the story
needed it to be in terms of the level of
a threat and what the music was telling
me you know I should be taking this
seriously
those elements did not line up like at
all and my assumption was the reason it
looks cute is because eventually it'll
be like oh but it's actually you know
it's a misunderstanding and it's not
inherently malicious which kind of
happens but they didn't really give it a
lot of like oh it's just a cute thing
moment which I was expecting them to do
so the fact that they didn't I mean I
suppose that's a good thing because
otherwise it would have been super
obvious and I would have called it but
at the same time if you're not gonna do
that
why does it look this cute like I said
it's it's it's just a weird choice given
how how much the episode in the music
especially are hammering home the danger
level of this thing it's just it doesn't
really work but like I said it's not I
don't think it's an awful episode the
impression I'm getting like from just
the I haven't watched anyone elses
review yet but the impression I'm
getting from just the general vibe is
not very positive on this one I don't
think it's that bad I think honestly
it's a fairly typical Chibnall episode
in that you know what people are hating
on this more than it's worth
it's not great but it's not that bad
which is about how I feel about 40 ^ 3
his salary a two-parter their fine and
here's I'm gonna like since this is the
halfway mark of the season
why don't we sort of and I don't have
too much more to say about this specific
episode let's pause for a second and
sort of give my thoughts about signals
writing right now I think in a lot of
ways we are seeing something that tracks
very well with the strengths that I saw
when I watched say broadchurch because
at the end of the day the strength of
broadchurch and again keep in mind I
only saw C's series 1 on that one I
didn't
really have time to do more than that
but the the strength of that show was in
the characters both in in their
conception and regional characterization
and also in the development of them over
time and I do honestly think that the
characters right now are the strengths
of this show as much as I may think jazz
is still a little bit of a hanger-on and
not doing as much she still solid I
really like Ryan I really like Graham I
am enjoying the doctor even though I'm
not completely in love with her yet the
characters are the strong suit which was
which i think is Chibnall strong sue the
problem is the actual stories are decent
but not great and also I think that's
kind of reflective of broadchurch as
well broadchurch is actual narrative is
fairly standard basic what makes it good
is the characters in the situation and
everything else the problem is is that
with that skillset he kind of got away
with it in broadchurch because it was a
setting in a scenario you know murder
mystery that people are very familiar
with audiences I mean so when we watch
that we're basically were there to latch
into the characters maybe some people
are there for the mystery but you know
having a really good well-developed
characters are is what's gonna set that
apart from the million other times
that's been done Doctor Who is or should
be doing stories that are not things
that you could just see anywhere else
and so while it is still good to have
the characters work with the stories
kind of need to be good if they need to
be landing harder they need to be a bit
more original a bit less per functor ii
than this and i think in a lot of ways
this supposition is gonna be put to the
test over the next four episodes from
here because the next four episodes were
written by other writers not even Chris
Chibnall as a co-writer because every
episode we've gotten so far the series
he either wrote himself or the case of
Rosa which while I have very complicated
feelings about that episode I do think
is probably
the best written episode that of the
series so far had a co-writer who was
some who was there even though the ghost
monument was probably episode I liked
the most I still wouldn't say that it's
necessarily the strongest writing in
terms of story there's a lot of stuff
that I liked about it but I still can't
say that like oh that's a strong story
episode and so that's where my concerns
are coming in at as we have hit the
midway point of this first series of
Whitaker's run is just that the the
character work is good and the cast is
good but the stories that they're being
put into are not much better than fine
and not not every episode of Doctor Who
ever has to have a mind-blowing story
were they were it's all about you know
the timey wimey Nisour it's it's you
know some big epic thing or whatever but
it doesn't need to be that every time
but yeah you can have you know episodes
like this that are that our lighter
episodes but with that feeling like it's
being the standard episode that that
worries me like I had been very
encouraged when I heard that they were
going to be focusing on standalone
episodes and not you know series arcs
which I think was a good thing but you
know when I think of great standalone
episodes of Doctor Who I think of things
like blink
I think of Vincent and the doctor I
think of the family of blood and human
nature I think you know that two-parter
impossible plan of the Satan pit all of
these are fantastic standalone episodes
and the standalone episodes that we're
getting it feels like there just isn't
as much effort being put into the story
element and I'm not saying there's no
effort being put in it all but it's
being put in on the character and some
of the production values because it
still looks pretty good even the
creature as much as I don't like the
design for totally CGI creature it's one
of the best
looking ones of that for Doctor Who
although when it eats things they just
kind of disappear into its mouth but you
know what how else you going to do that
but that this something this small
eating as much as it is but you know
visually they the shows look good the
acting is good the characters are good
but it feels like the the concepts the
the the stories the writing the the
thrusts of the episodes outside of you
know what the characters are doing the
actual situations they're being put in
are just okay and that's that's a little
concerning so I guess I'll leave it
there like I said I there isn't really
much to say about this episode it's a
couple of things I liked a couple of
things I didn't it runs neutral it's fun
so yeah so that and my thoughts on the
series so far were being about midway
through what are your thoughts about
this episode whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it whole bunch of stuff you
can do down there too because there's
links and there's buttons including like
to my patreon if you feel like
supporting me that way if you don't
though
don't sweat it because at the end of the
day you are the council and I just run
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]